hey twitter boy dakar pentax how you
feel when using a car binding texts
comeback climate change
okay ah end flat op posing design sls
it's called
to use texas now just being or all you have
them there and direction looks like a never
idle like china briefing is  likely to be
fixed we the text of an account to
educate for etex highlight the wheely's
earrings impact evil the east lies
with stacks stacks than alcohol minecraft
stretching that and the ibood.nl and the man and woman
louisa actually is more nuance
nat'lly  communion simple in a
progressive taxation system
wino away and progressive tax at a very
tough and money and by the very rich
which is most likely serine
bank account
in sterrebeek scans us the pony from
sorry who now that is better for the
economy is that's no money  that would
likely have high multiplier effective is
the rich people who care jack skype and and
towards more construction of two million
dollars
it's no money that the kidney in the snap
but everyone  is liquides am anyway the
using web way of programs for people
who actually not the way that is
economic mystim you have to it so that
spain use it gets to is it no will
interfere with the content iss shell to
ripe for my talk ah so
in the  same way ajax oil have see and
number kubb studies with scarlet witch is
epke country and big corporate level a
good way secretly at climate change i
made some crazy like you pay the periods
network
webmoney absolutely can be used in ways
that will marketing out as the  words just
that wants to drop off pollution that is
created by the powders and i in knowledge and
just lower downtown pollution and death
surf help to mitigate or prevent
the climate  am in favor of
responsible a deck of cards table
carbon texas the comeback climate change
when applied essentially called in
demonstrate and and this is okay
okay form richard ex
the auctions  family brother whatever will
really not touch our coats bridge to
meet the for future
the cart ben texas abuse in the short term
the sales pollution board in the launcher
me to both companies and countries tiga
van fossil fuels
touchpad something after that of the texts
pioneer in  the future
that my unitary specifically had something after
and not my figure gives
current country style with tax wonderfully
thick corporation for the construction union
flogging small businesses on the three
large and small businesses
je bent u in de which will get
mechanics have seen anything on  you
know there already lie to you by an
airline cheap air
you feel like a fuel surcharge touch
for the cost fuel eye idle well die
live media or passing passers die
individual consumer be chris ultimately
the individual consumer working as a
group in the videos consumer in  the
jogging had to can love before she tried
i said it become a burqa companies
the edge switching to [ __ ] youtube
renewable energy  wiser responsibility'
i think that is definitely also called
seaweed identified des kreises that we
have their country and looking for now
exactly that skype and texas and youtube
comeback climate change in the types of
medium term with the medium too slowly
deafblind i already of us all
together zo use my my my [ __ ] fabio i
je disagree with me de table je pride
carbon texas
actually work when i know if you this
together on principle line-up really care
to hear from you
de marge quite frankly arno he quietly
willingly eye catcher
if you wanna 9 case there is no way the
pushed carbon texas in a way that works
and when families is that we left that side
the studies that red